kovid's grim patchwork
delhi's main muslim cemetery for victims
of the pandemic
is almost full
[Music]
india is in the grip of a surging
epidemic cases have passed
200 000 a day a spike driven in part by
a new
mutated version of the virus it's
already spreading across borders
new figures from public health england
show there have been 77
cases in the uk scientists say the
evolution of the variant
is an inevitable consequence of india's
infection rate
the more transmission you get the more
people that are infected
the the more variance you'll get it
really is that straightforward
the indian variant called b1617 has
two key mutations in its spike protein
the first is called
l452r which is also found in a variant
circulating in california
although the indian virus has evolved
independently
the second is called e484q
a completely new mutation lab tests
suggest
both help the virus infect cells and
evade antibodies
and while it's still unknown what real
world effect that would have on vaccines
the combination gives it the hallmark of
a dangerous virus
public health england is tracing
contacts of those infected
as it also steps up surge testing for
the south african variant
another 56 cases have been detected in
the uk in the last week
bringing the total to 600. in south
london where public health teams are
dealing with a cluster of cases
people are still coming forward for
testing some still planning to meet
friends this weekend
he's still planning to uh go out but i
thought it's the best thing i guess to
come and get tested
after hearing everything on the news
people are just going out like
regularly so like i kind of like i'm a
bit worried about like the spread of the
new disease
a little scared i think possibly
but what can we do we try and be
sensible
the spread of variants brought into the
uk has led to renewed criticism of the
government's travel controls
india is not on the red list of
countries with travel bans and hotel
quarantines
instead people are trusted to stay at
home
it just doesn't work says this expert
this
year we have to be just incredibly
strict and do what new zealand and
australia do and do every every person
comes in has to do 10-day managed hotel
isolation
and particularly as we're rolling out
the vaccination you know we have put all
of our eggs in the vaccine basket
the vaccines work brilliantly well and
the one thing that could be a potential
risk to that
is a new variant that can overcome the
back the protection from vaccines
boris johnson is due to visit india
later this month despite the
accelerating epidemic
downing street said safety is paramount
and the prime minister will follow any
quarantine rules on his return
it added that the red list of countries
is under constant review
thomas more sky news